If you want to get lost at sea in the best way possible,...
...you need to head to the Maldives.
The Maldives is a tropical nation in the Indian Ocean comprised of 26 ring-shaped atolls,...
...which are made up of more than 1,000 coral islands.
It's known for its beaches, blue lagoons and extensive reefs.
Now, when you go to the Maldives,...
...you have two options for places to stay.
The first, you pay a ton of money and you stay in a very nice all-inclusive resort.
They were saying it is 10,000 dollars per night for the top room here.
The second, you travel with some friends, hire a surf boat and just island-hop.
There is nothing in the whole world like living on a boat in the middle of the Indian Ocean.
Early September is a good time to visit.
The weather was beautiful and the surf was very, very good.
And if you're not into surfing, you can always island-hop and hang out with some locals,...
...go freediving on one of the many reefs or even find your deserted island all to yourself.